hey what's up my name's samuel leeds and
in this video i want to talk to you
about hmos
and how i believe they are pretty much
recession
proof through what's going to
potentially happen in this economy over
the coming months and
years if you enjoy my videos please do
smash the like button
and let me know that you like my videos
because i put out a video every single
day
and it takes me a lot of time so if you
appreciate it and if you want me to keep
making videos
let me know by smashing the like button
that thumb needs to be up and it needs
to be blue
also if you like my videos please do
subscribe and turn the notification bell
on because there's going to be some
ridiculously exciting videos coming up
real soon which you do not want to miss
so don't just subscribe
but also turn the notification bell on
so hmos people are saying to me
samuel what's going to happen with hmos
if there's a recession because people
won't be able to afford to pay rent the
people that say that i'm not
really thinking this through because in
a recession what happens
well people i mean there's three d's
usually in the recession there's death
divorce and default payments that's what
happens in recessions
so if there's divorces okay now by the
way i don't like divorces i think it's
sad i think it's a shame
i wish that people didn't get divorced
but let's just look at this from a
pure business point of view if
a couple split up that couple
were used to having two wages and living
in one house
suddenly they're going to split up which
means that they're going to have
way less money for rent so what kind of
accommodation
do you think they're going to need to
start looking for probably affordable
accommodation
such as what such as renting a room
so if there's recession and then there's
certainly lots of divorces happening and
there is right
now divorce rates spiking up partly that
might be because of lockdown because
people suddenly realize that
they don't like each other as much as
they thought but they're going to need
to suddenly start renting things like
rooms so
so divorce is probably going to help
hmos
if you'd agree let me know in the
comments but also defaults
default payments why do people default
on their mortgage payments why do people
default on their rent payments why do
people default on their bills it's
because they haven't got much money
because in recession people don't have
much money so what is
the most affordable accommodation in the
uk if you're a professional person
and you just want really affordable
accommodation what is it it's hmos
it's renting a house of multiple
occupancy so
what i personally found through the
2008-2009 crash
was i found that people were queuing up
to rent my rooms
maybe they were divorced guys maybe
they're people that were downsizing
maybe they're people that are getting
fired and relocating and still need a
new accommodation i want to rent
somewhere for six twelve months and
they're looking for a hmo
so in my mind not only are hmos a
fantastic
product or service because think about
this okay property investing is just a
business
your house is your products your tenant
is your customer it's just a business
a hmo is a product the rooms are a
product so
what do you get when you rent a hmo or
you get a room and an
ensuite maybe or maybe a shared bathroom
you get a furnished room
the bills are all included there's super
fast wi-fi and how much you on average
you're gonna charge for that room
about four or five hundred pounds a
month so from a
from a tenant's perspective they can
either rent a
apartment or a studio apartment for
about four or five hundred pounds a
month
plus on top of that they're gonna have
to pay their bills they're gonna have to
pay council tax they're gonna have to
sort out their broadband they're gonna
have to furnish it they have to pay
big deposits and this that okay fine but
you're probably gonna end up costing
about
eight nine ten hundred pound a month
just to have a roof over their head
so they can either do that or they can
rent a room off me
for four or five hundred pound a month
everything's all included nice and easy
the only thing is they have to share
some of the communal areas no big deal
so what i think is going to happen is i
think that hmos
i think that rents are going to go up i
think that we're going to have
more demand for hmos i was just with a
hmm management company in
burnley now burnley's a really cheap
area you can buy a house in burnley for
like 60 or 70 grand
the hr management company in burnley
said to me that she
has got um 200 rooms and of the 200
rooms
she's only got four rooms that are empty
that's
incredible and those four rooms that are
empty she said there are tenants
booked ready to move in she told me that
she's got
hundreds of people on her waiting list
looking for rooms and she is desperate
for more rooms so as a hmo
property investor you should be feeling
pretty excited right now
because when the demand is high the
supply is getting lower
they're bringing article 4 into new
areas but they need to give 12 months
notice when they bring in article 4
so you want to buy you want to turn into
a hmo
let let article 4 come in have the
grandfather rights kill off the more
competition
let the rents go up let as the recession
comes let people downsize into your
brilliant hmos
some of you are being greedy now i'm not
being greedy i'm just i'm just offering
what the marketplace wants an
entrepreneur is someone that says
what do people want and then you give it
to them and my hmos right now are doing
pretty well
and i think it's only going to get
better so as the recession gets worse
i think it's a bulletproof property
investment strategy as
the economy goes downhill as a potential
i mean even when lockdown happened
everyone was all like oh my gosh what's
gonna happen with hmos
well when lockdown happened my hmo
tenants were locked in to my hmos
i mean geez that's not that bad from
from an investor's point of view
you know what about tenant what about
tenant eviction bans listen you know
what i think about eviction bans
i'm really angry about it i think it's
stupid luckily
my tenants are all paying rent but a few
who we're working with
88 percent of tenants in the country in
the uk even
are paying full rent an additional seven
are paying part rent so it's only a few
percentage that aren't paying any rent
and to be honest that's probably the
case normally so
you know yeah i know i did an angry
video the other day about tenant
eviction bans but let's not blow things
out of proportion
let's keep things let's keep things
recession proof let's invest
smart and uh as your
guy who teaches you about property maybe
i'm your go-to guy
i i don't know i just want to make sure
that i'm putting out you know
practical information and i want to give
you the good i want to give you the bad
so i'm excited about hmos i think it's a
good way to go i don't know what you
think let me know in the comments below
if you want to learn more about the
basics of what are hmos and how to get
them
you can check this video out right here
if you want to see my angry rant about
the tenant eviction bans that i did last
week
you can check that out right here and
please do me a massive favor though and
subscribe to my youtube channel
right here the recession is coming it is
here but it's going to be okay that's my
opinion
what's yours comment below